it is a real pleasure to welcome to the
program today noam chomsky one of the
most renowned intellectuals of our time
and author of over 25 books including
chomsky for activists universalizing
resistance uh professor it's so great
having you on today i appreciate it
very pleased to be with you
so i would love to start by getting your
thoughts about
how
the the current state of the american
right and the republican party got to
where it is today
there's this line that is sometimes
traced that goes back to
anger stemming from the civil rights
movement into the reagan era of being
against welfare
through to the gingrich era of the early
90s and radicalization and this sort of
progression that led to
the trumpian era how do you see this
progression of the last 40 50
that's
years
pretty accurate description
goes back to
richard nixon who
recognized that uh
the republican party could
pick up
southern
democratic votes by
essentially being
a racist party
didn't put it in those words of course
but essentially by uh
in various
indirect
fashions making it clear that they
opposed the civil rights movement
the
there had been a solid
democratic bloc of
southern democrats they were
strongly opposed to the
johnson support for the
early civil rights movement and
this was called nixon's southern
strategy and nothing secret about it was
quite open
we have to recognize that the
republicans
have a certain problem
of the two political parties they are
the one that is
more supportive
of
business rights and the very rich
and you can't approach voters
saying
i want to support
the very rich
and the corporate world
and harm you so please vote for me
that obviously doesn't work
we have to look for other issues
what are called cultural issues things
that are apart from the actual
programs of the party
the programs of the party are very clear
strong support for extreme wealth
and corporate power it's perfectly
obvious during the trump years
the one legislative achievement was a
tax bill that benefited the extreme rich
and extreme wealth
and cut back of corporate taxes
deregulation the sports business and so
on
you can't approach voters that way so
they've had to look for something else
well nixon's
southern strategy was a story
in the
mid 1970s
uh leading republican strategist paul
virus
who's a christian nationalist
he realized that
if the republicans
pretended to be opposed to abortion
i stress pretended that they could pick
up the
huge evangelical vote
and
make inroads into the northern catholic
food
so he proposed that to the party they
all switched on a dime
they had mostly been what we now call
pro-choice
when reagan was
governor
california and 1960s passed a very
strong
pro choice
legislation
but in the mid 70s they all switched
entirely
reagan george h.w bush
the whole flew in them
so they became
pretended anti-abortions
then
the next thing was to pick up on gun
rights they're in favor of guns they
don't care one way or another but that's
the way you can pick up more votes
and so it continues
when reagan came along
the party became
pretty openly racist
reagan himself was a
dedicated racist he wasn't pretending
so he
his uh
he opened his campaign as you recall in
1980
in philadelphia mississippi a
town which is known for only one thing
my civil rights workers were murdered
there
the republicans pretended it was an
accident but nobody could miss it yeah
then came the stories about welfare
queens
black of course says stealing your money
and so on in fact reagan was so racist
that he was the last
leader in the world
to support the apartheid regime in south
africa at a time when everyone else had
left thatcher israel everyone reagan was
still supporting it
in fact as late as
uh
1988
it was all over by then
uh the reagan administration declared
the
nelson mandela's
african national congress to be
one of the more notorious terrorist
groups in the world and mandela himself
was on the terrorist list
couldn't visit the united states
without special authorization for about
20 years until
congress finally passed some
about it
well so that's racism then comes
gingrich
who
reconstructed the
congress the republican congressional
delegation
so that it became
kind of like the old communist party
it's or it's a
top-down organized everyone has to agree
its role is obstructionist
that became
open
not even hidden under mitch mcconnell
when obama was elected obama
mcconnell's came straight out and said
our task is to make sure he can do
nothing we've just seen that again now
mcconnell's repeated the same point
we have to make sure we block him on
everything
make the country ungovernable
and
meanwhile the
the policies of the political party
have
changed as well
so for example in
john mccain when he ran in
2008
i had
uh
a
change pro
[Music]
plank in his program
not
not very far-reaching but it was there
and the republicans in the senate were
considering
climate change legislation
the koch brothers energy conglomerate
had been working for years to ensure
that the republicans
would never
veer towards
recognizing global warming and they were
infuriated they launched a huge campaign
major juggernaut
bribing senators threatening them with
primary challenges
a huge lobbying campaign astroturf the
republicans totally changed from that
point on
total climate denial
that's the way it stands today
and professor on that note you i think
this is a really important thing
particularly for my audience which is
mostly on the left to here you mentioned
john mccain in contrast to some of these
other wings of the right there are some
who recently for example when mitt
romney
voted to convict donald trump on one of
those impeachment
accounts or when liz cheney was removed
from republican leadership simply for
saying listen trump won we have to
accept that there are some on the left
who have reacted by saying fundamentally
these people are no different than
the marjorie taylor greens and the most
extreme of the republican party while
others believe no there is an important
difference between people like mccain
and romney and those that have taken
over the party now do you believe that
the difference is a materially
significant difference
there is a difference
and
mccain had whatever you think about his
policies i didn't like him i mean
but nevertheless he was
sort of a human being
decent human being in some ways had some
degree of integrity yeah that's
disappeared from the party i mean when
you look at them now they're
virtually all
cowering in terror
before the trump rebel
you can just see it in every act that
they make
blocking the inquiry commission the
votes on i mean the votes on the
stimulus were quite interesting
the republican party
the legislators
know very well
that their own constituents
favored
largely favored the stimulus
they themselves largely proposed
support them but they voted as a block
against it
you have to
the highest priority
is make the country ungovernable
prevent anything from happening
find a way to get back into power
so we can then worship trump and
go ahead and destroy the world i mean
trump's climate change policies alone
forgetting everything else
another four years of that would
probably carry us to irreversible
tipping points
the game could very well be over
and if you look at the republican base
they're
caught in this trap
a kind of an echo chamber trap
they hear
the republican leadership
now it's trump worship
uh they turn on the fox news
reiterates it it's an echo chamber
uh listen to
rush limbaugh when he was alive he tells
them
same thing
take a look at the attitudes
it's terrifying
for example there was recently a
pew
poll the main polling agency studies
public attitudes
they ask people a
simple question here they give them
15 choices
of to rank as which were the urgent
problems that we have to face
a split between democrats and
republicans
among republicans
the lowest of the 15
was climate change
14
thought that was a serious problem the
highest problem
greatest problem we face is
illegal immigration and the deficit
the deficit became a problem on november
4th indeed for that it was fine the line
was reagan taught us that deficits don't
matter
so trump punched a huge hole in the
deficit that was fine
but november 4th
the democrats the deficit is the highest
problem we face
and whatever you think about illegal
immigration it's
uh there are problems but it's nothing
remotely like
globally warming which is going to
destroy organized human life on earth
but that's
14
the lowest of all the problems well you
put yourself in the position of a
republican voter
you can understand it
you hear trump
you hear the republican leadership
you listen to fox news
they say it's just a liberal hoax maybe
the chinese are doing
so what do you want to believe
that's a really you're
faced with a really serious problem
the
republican party has just gone off the
rails
even uh
mainstream commentators described them
as
a radical insurgency
that has abandoned parliamentary
politics and you can see it in
the actions particularly since gingrich
bastard mcconnell and so on
i'm curious you know one of the toughest
things that i've not even come up with
any good ideas on to be perfectly frank
is
how can you do a mass
deprogramming if you consider this a
brainwashing that has taken place that
could have any
real impact on attitudes i mean even a
few weeks ago more than half of the
party believes that donald trump is the
rightful winner many believe that he's
inevitably going to take back the white
house at some point in the next year
i know that individual conversations
with people it can take months of
building a relationship before you get
someone to re-examine their beliefs
that's not a wholesale strategy what do
you see
is there a way i guess is the question
to deal with this at a large scale
yes there is that's the strategy
and in fact there's some positive signs
so if you look more closely at the
republican party
the younger sectors the millennials
they're
getting coming to be different
they're it's it's the older part of the
party
that's driving towards these
highly destructive policies
among younger people it's different
and they are reachable
uh
it's hard work
has to be done
personal conversations organization
educational programs can have an effect
we can see it ourselves i mean
i mean what's the liberal population
it's quite different from what it was
40 or 50 years ago yeah
take take the reaction to the
george floyd murder
it's quite remarkable
uh
the largest social movement in american
history developed
spontaneously
why because there had been years of work
to change people's attitudes and
consciousness
black lives matter and others
they'd prepared the ground
so that when this volvo murder took
place it exploded
uh
you can take the
1619 project
of the new york times
it couldn't have happened a few years
ago
there's a general
steady change in consciousness
see it on many other issues
take the issue
just the recent
israeli
destruction of gaza once again
the reaction was quite different than in
the past
for the first time ever
you had
correspondence in
the mainstream in the new york times
saying
we have to stop military aid israel
that would have been inconceivable a
couple of years ago
and it's across the board
take a look at evangelicals
by far the strongest support for israel
no matter what it does any crime is okay
except that younger ones are moving away
recent studies of evangelicals show that
younger evangelicals are
reassessing their position rethinking
this
and the same on other issues
so
it's not a the game isn't over it's hard
work but it can be achieved
it can be achieved by
sympathetic understanding
of where they are
where they're coming from
finding common ground
moving towards areas which all of us can
understand and nobody wants the world to
burn to become a hot house earth
in which humans can't survive
okay
let's bring the
understanding of this to the general
population with hard work
the way it's been done on
many other issues it takes a feminist
issues
and go back to the 1960s they didn't
exist
nothing you know okay
now lots of understanding
so changes can take place in fact it's
kind of useful to go back to the 60s and
see what the country was like then
before the
activism of the 60s
i mean in the 1960s
federal laws
required segregation and housing
blacks could not
break into the housing market
public housing was blocked by federal
laws
we had
anti-miscegenation laws
that were so extreme that the nazis
wouldn't accept them
this is the 1960s yeah
okay
all that is
inconceivable today
professor i don't want to keep you too
much longer but i did want to get your
thoughts on you know some of the debates
you participated in over the years
uh with william f buckley with foucault
and so many others that still are so
watched on youtube and other platforms
today
and thinking back to them now
what stands out about them what what do
you remember what seems to you to be
notable about them as as somebody who
participated in them and was there in
the room for many of those conversations
well
they're different
a foucault
serious person we were talking about
real issues
you can have an opinion on them but
with buckley it was quite different
my impression of buckley was that he was
just a fraud
i mean he
had a nice style you know
he he's as if he knew what he was
talking about um
as soon as you begin you look at the
debate you can see it
as soon as you get into any particular
issue
it quickly changes the subject
because he basically doesn't know
anything about it
he can try to overwhelm you with his uh
rhetorical style and so on
i thought he was all surface
in fact you couldn't see it in the
debate but
at the end
he was so infuriated
that he would get
he left the
studio screaming at me
saying you know we'll have you back and
show you a thing or two or something
like that wasn't recorded
but my impression of him was that
if he just
kept calm and quiet and tried to talk
about him within about issues it would
collapse
what was was foucault or are there
others that in thinking back you say
this is someone who challenged me not
just rhetorically but really
substantively this was really where i
was the most
challenged well it was
we disagreed on a number of things but
at least we were talking about real
issues
i should say that there's a little
background to that
uh
foucault
i i don't know any any french who code
doesn't speak english
but we spent the afternoon together
before the debate
just walking around the dutch
countryside
uh partly just
because we wanted to talk to each other
informally but partly to see if we could
get by
with him talking french and me talking
english
and or did we need a translator
so we figured we could kind of make it
with
and
we
decided to wing it and do it without a
translator which sort of worked but
i should tell you something else
which didn't show on the television yeah
foucault you know is totally bold yeah
yeah
the moderator fonts elders
a very interesting person he was a dutch
anarchist
there was a dutch anarchist movement at
that time which was
doing all sorts of things like
giving lsd to
horses at fancy
sports shows so that they'd jump all
over the place
on the way to the studio
fonts elder stopped at his apartment
went upstairs came down
he had a bright red wig
in his hand
and through the whole debate
if you notice closely he was nudging
cuckoo and saying put it on put it on
that is an incredible detail
that is something else uh well listen uh
professor noam chomsky i i so appreciate
your time today and the fact that we
were able to do this and to put it
together uh really thank you so much for
your time i so appreciate having you on
thank you